un bijou de technologie mais un joyau de
620 millions de francs l'unité
peut être trop voyants quand l'heure est
aux économies en matière de défense
rumeur officieuse les commandes du
rafale serait repousser voire annuler
une douche froide car en 1986 c'est bien
jacques chirac alors premier ministre
qui avait donné son feu vert au
lancement du rafale un programme
beaucoup à l'époque jugé exorbitant par
beaucoup de spécialistes dont les value
aujourd'hui entre 70 et 100 milliards de
francs au total
serge dassault est suffisamment inquiet
pour s'offrir ce matin une page entière
de publicité dans la presse
en ile de france inclus vélizy et
argenteuil puis de 4000 salariés sont
directement concernés
les quatre premiers avions de combat
sont d'ailleurs sortis des chaînes de
montage francilienne la société dassault
s'est adapté à la situation
d'aujourd'hui par et nude personnel on
admirait nos structures
on a réuni 2 aux usines très bien adapté
à condition que on continue avec les
programmes prévus cette année heures
comment on n'aura pas les merdes jamais
le pré-u la diversification du groupe
vers l'industrie civile est plutôt une
réussite sa filiale dassault
électronique installé entre autres à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines réalise déjà
un peu moins de la moitié de son chiffre
d'affaires en dehors du militaire
monétique bancaire télécommunications
sont des secteurs où dassault a su
s'imposer
seulement cela représente à l'échelle de
l'entreprise une goutte d'eau alors les
7000 salariés de la région sont
suspendues aux conclusions du président
de la république à la fin de la semaine
jacques chirac devrait choisir entre un
porte avions nucléaire le charles de
gaulle
un hélicoptère furtif le nh90 et un
avion de combat le rafale trois
programmes que la france n'a plus les
moyens de financer en totalité